[Musica]
spazio ultima frontiera noi astronomi
proprio come il capitano kirk a bordo
della sua nave stellare enterprise
esploriamo il cosmo alla ricerca di
strani nuovi mondi ma essendo abbastanza
pigri e soprattutto privi di un motore a
curvatura lo facciamo comodamente seduti
alle nostre scrivanie o saltuariamente
dalla sala controllo di un qualche
telescopio in qualche angolo remoto del
pianeta
occhi aperti e orecchie tese cerchiamo
di captare ogni singolo segnale che il
cosmo ci invia non soltanto alla luce
delle stelle della galassia che
raccogliamo con i grandi telescopi
ottici quelli fatti di lenti e di
specchi ma anche ad esempio raggi ics a
raggi gamma che captiamo tramite
satelliti artificiali che mettiamo in
orbita attorno alla terra segnali che
sono prodotti dai fenomeni più violenti
dell'universo
esplosioni stellari collisioni tra corpi
celesti tra buchi neri ad esempio tra
stelle di neutroni oppure con strumenti
come questo cerchiamo di raccogliere i
deboli segni i deboli segnali di onde
radio che este e le galassie gas
interstellari naturalmente e mettano la
storia che voglio raccontarvi questa
sera comincia proprio qui a questo
radiotelescopio è un'antenna gigantesca
64 metri di diametro che si chiama
radiotelescopio di parkes e che è
situata in una remota zona
dell'australia orientale
la storia comincia il 24 luglio del 2001
esattamente alle 5 50 del mattino quando
un improvviso rapidissimo lampo di onde
radio proveniente dallo spazio profondo
colpisce il nostro telescopio che ne
registra il segnale sul nastro magnetico
questo segnale però è così debole
no non tanto debole mai così breve e
così elusivo che gli astronomi
nell'analizzare i dati raccolti in quei
giorni inizialmente non lo notano se
sarà soltanto nel 2007 sei anni dopo che
applicando nuovi algoritmi
ai dati raccolti quella notte
riusciranno finalmente a metterlo in
luce a tirarlo fuori dal rumore che lo
circondava eccolo lì un segnale
brevissimo appena un millesimo di
secondo di durata ma se andiamo ad
analizzare da vicino ci possiamo rendere
conto che quel segnale prima di arrivare
al nostro telescopio deve aver
attraversato spazi cosmici immensi deve
aver viaggiato per centinaia di milioni
di anni
si tratta di un tipo di segnale che
nessuno aveva mai visto prima
probabilmente in qualche nuovo fenomeno
cosmico tutto da esplorare per cercare
di capire di che cosa si potesse
trattare e per cercare soprattutto di
confermare che fosse veramente un evento
cosmico un evento astronomico non
qualche segnale prodotto da
un'apparecchiatura terrestre gli
astronomi cominciano ad andare a
guardare nei dati raccolti negli anni
precedenti a tutti i vari telescopi per
cercare di trovare qualche segnale
simile una rondine sappiamo non fa prima
a primavera ma uno stormo sì
inizialmente però non trovano nulla anzi
peggio nei dati di archivio del
radiotelescopio di parkes trovano 16
brevi segnali piuttosto simili a questo
ma chiaramente di origine terrestre
registrati in giorni diversi anche a
mesi di distanza gli uni dagli altri
tutti però avevano la peculiare
caratteristica di apparire intorno
all'ora di pranzo il colpevole viene
presto trovato nel forno a microonde del
centro visite del radiotelescopio di
parkes si scopre che aprendo lo
sportello di quel forno a microonde
prima della fine del timer
esattamente un impulso di onde radio
molto intenso viene prodotto brevissimo
e investe il nostro radiotelescopio da
sotto non dal cielo
il lampo del 2001 però qualche
caratteristica diversa
e del resto è stato registrato alle 5 50
del mattino quando il centro visite e
chiuso il suo forno a microonde
sicuramente spento la speranza che
quello fosse veramente un segnale
astronomico e non un qualche incidente
gastronomico era ancora viva tanto che
tutte le volte che il telescopio veniva
puntato a qualche altra sorgente per
studiare qualche altro fenomeno cosmico
tutti i dati venivano comunque
analizzati alla ricerca di segnali di
quel tipo per cercare di confermarne la
natura veramente astrofisica
ci sono voluti altri cinque anni ma a
partire dal 2012 anche grazie ad
avanzamenti tecnologici ai nostri
radiotelescopi prima un lampo poi un
altro poi altri due altre tre hanno
cominciato pian piano essere scoperti e
registrati da tutti i più grandi radio
telescopi sulla terra
tutti compreso tanto per fugare ogni
dubbio questo che ha un'enorme antenna
parabolica 100 metri di diametro che si
trova negli stati uniti in questi
vaccini e si chiama green bank radio
telescope e per 30 chilometri attorno a
questo telescopio nessuno può possedere
né un forno a microonde né un telefono
cellulare nulla del genere nulla che
possa produrre segnali tali da
interferire con i delicati strumenti che
devono captare i segnali così più deboli
che il cosmo e mette
ebbene da allora dal 2012 ad oggi sono
passati dieci anni abbiamo scoperto
centinaia di questi lampi dal cosmo i
nostri cataloghi ne contengono adesso
circa 660 se non erro e ne scopriamo
ogni giorno di più
gli abbiamo anche dato un nome abbiamo
poca fantasia noi astronomi a dire la
verità si chiamano f r b dall acronimo
dell'inglese fastre di lampi radio
veloci poca fantasia dicevo ne
conosciamo 600 e la maggior parte è
stata vista solo una volta un brevissimo
lampo che è comparso per un millesimo di
secondo nel cielo e poi nulla più c'è
una piccola sottoclasse di questi lampi
che invece stiamo studiando con molta
più attenzione perché possiamo
permettercelo grazie al fatto che hanno
mostrato più di un lampo provenire dalla
stessa zona di cielo ed alla stessa
distanza cosmica una piccola quantità di
questi lampi di questi 600 f r b hanno
poi anche per una piccola quantità di
questi l'anti siamo anche poi stati in
grado di fare una fotografia della
galassia che le contiene che li ha
prodotti
la fotografia fatta non con un
radiotelescopio ma con un telescopio
ottico
accoglie la luce delle stelle e questo è
un compito non semplice perché un
radiotelescopio
inquadra con un unico pixel un'area di
cielo per ogni volta che fa un
osservazione piccolissima grande più o
meno un decimo dell'area e che copre nel
cielo la luna un'area veramente piccola
ma se andiamo a vedere
quest'area quanti galassi contiene
e bene vediamo che ce ne sono centinaia
anzi migliaia a capire quali di queste
migliaia sia stata quella in cui è nato
il nostro lampo di onde radio è
complicatissimo e necessario far
lavorare insieme una rete di
radiotelescopi che tutti simultaneamente
devono vedere questo brevissimo lampo di
un millesimo di secondo e con una
complicata triangolazione riuscire ad
individuare un punto nell'universo
piccolissimo in cui ci sia solo una
galassia
eccone qui un esempio questa è una
galassia delle 24 che siamo stati in
grado di fotografare da cui è provenuto
uno di questi rapidissimi lampi di onde
radio
conosciamo appunto 600 lampi ma non
sappiamo ancora cosa sono quali sono le
caratteristiche che conosciamo di questi
lampi sappiamo che sono brevissimi
qualche millesimo di secondo
da questo possiamo dedurre che il corpo
che li hai messi deve essere molto
piccolo più piccolo di un pianeta più
piccolo della luna piccolo quanto è una
città appena qualche decina di
chilometri di diametro
sappiamo anche vediamo qui che
provengono da galassie molto distanti
che il loro segnale deve aver
attraversato spazi cosmici e aver
viaggiato per anche miliardi di anni
prima di giungere al nostro telescopio
questo significa che affinché i nostri
telescopi siano comunque stati in grado
di captare in maniera relativamente
chiara il fenomeno che li ha prodotti
così tanto tempo fa è così distante deve
essere stato immensamente potente in
appena un millesimo di secondo
deve aver emesso tutta l'energia che il
sole emette in un intero anno corpi
molto piccoli e molto energetici dunque
sapendo poi per quanto tempo abbiamo
osservato il cielo con i nostri
radiotelescopi alla loro ricerca e
quanta aria di cielo è stata coperta
alla loro ricerca possiamo domandarci
poiché ne abbiamo visti i 600 quanti ce
ne devono essere in tutto il cielo ogni
giorno
ebbene la risposta è abbastanza
sorprendente ce ne devono essere circa
mille ogni giorno circa uno ogni minuto
qualcosa di più anche sembrano
tantissimi come ci avete messo di 10
anni e ne avete visti seicento quando ce
ne mille al giorno ma se ci pensate
ognuno dura un millesimo di secondo
quindi mille al giorno significa un
secondo al giorno e noi non sappiamo
ciascuno di questi mille dove apparirà o
quando ricordiamoci poi che i nostri
telescopi inquadrano un'area di cielo
piccolissima più piccola dell'unghia del
nostro mignolo proiettata in cielo
pensare di riuscire ad acchiappare anche
solo uno di questi mille lampi al
momento giusto al posto giusto guardando
uno spicchio di cielo così piccolo è
difficile effettivamente come se noi
provassimo durante la notte di san
lorenzo a guardare il cielo in cerca
delle stelle cadenti osservandolo
attraverso il foro di una cannuccia
complicatissimo no e in più le stelle
cadenti durano di più di un millesimo di
secondo e lasciano anche una scia
che cosa possiamo ancora a domandarci
beh noi sappiamo che nell'universo ci
sono circa 200 miliardi di galassie
quindi tutto sommato fare 200 da 200
miliardi galassie mille lampi al secondo
si riduce a fare a produrre in una unica
galassia che contiene miliardi di stelle
a sua volta un solo lampo ogni 100 200
anni sono in realtà fenomeni abbastanza
rari mille al giorno sono pochi a tutti
gli effetti
ogni volta che ne osserviamo uno nuovo
però impariamo qualcosa di nuovo
aggiungiamo un piccolo tassello al
grande puzzle che compone il mistero di
questi f r b è un puzzle ancora pieno di
buchi tanto che sono state sviluppate
finora a decine di diverse teorie per
cercare di spiegare la loro virgin è
la più tra le più accreditate quelle che
hanno diciamo più indizi a loro favore
ci sono delle teorie che dicono che
l'origine di questi lampi sia un tipo di
stelle molto particolare si chiama
martin e tar sono delle stelle
piccolissime 20 km di diametro circa che
però condensano al loro interno una
volta e mezzo la massa del nostro sole
un cucchiaino di questa stella sulla
terra peserebbe quanto l'umanità intera
in più come suggerisce il loro nome
matnet all anno dei campi magnetici
intensissimi un milione di miliardi più
volti di volte più forti del campo
magnetico della nostra terra così forti
questi campi magnetici che potrebbero
proprio essere il motore che produce
l'energia di cui abbiamo necessità per
fare questi lampi di onde radio oggetti
piccoli e pieni di energia rimangono
però in ballo ancora diverse teorie per
cercare di spiegare l'origine di questi
lampi tra le più curiose e francamente
meno plausibile delle quali ci sono
addirittura gli alieni immancabili a
tutti gli effetti però non sappiamo
ancora che cosa produca questi
misteriosi
l'anpi e cerchiamo ancora di capirlo e
di comprenderlo però una cosa sappiamo
sappiamo che questi lampi per giungere
fino a noi hanno attraversato distanze
cosmiche immense possiamo dunque a tutti
gli effetti
utilizzarli come sonde per studiare
l'universo e per provare a rispondere ad
altre domande aperte dell'astrofisica ad
esempio una domanda che attanaglia la
comunità scientifica da un pezzo quanto
gas dove tutto il gas nell'universo le
teorie cosmologiche quelle cioè che ci
cercano di spiegare come è nato e come
evolve a partire dal big bang il nostro
universo dicono che ci deve essere un
certo quantitativo di materia normale
lasciamo lasciamo per ora da parte la
misteriosa materia oscura di gas in
parole povere
però se noi andiamo a misurare tutto il
gas che riusciamo a vedere sotto forma
di stella galassie polveri o gas
interstellari tutto ciò che riusciamo a
farla chi appare con i nostri telescopi
quelli ottici quelli radio quelli che
raccolgono registra di gamma eccetera ci
accorgiamo che una buona metà di questa
materia prevista manca all'appello
c'è però per fortuna una particolarità
una caratteristica delle onde radio e
quindi anche dei nostri misteriosi lampi
di onde radio che ci viene in aiuto e
cioè il fatto che un'onda radio quando
viaggia nel cosmo ogni volta che
incontra una particella di gas le viene
frenata non tutte le onde radio però
vengono frenate alla stessa maniera le
onde radio di frequenza più elevata
vengono frenate meno le onde radio di
frequenza più bassa vengono frenate via
via contrario quelle di frequenza più
elevata vengono frenate di più quelli di
frequenza più bassa vengono frenate via
via di meno arrivano sempre più tardi
allora noi cosa possiamo fare andando a
misurare il ritardo con cui la
componente a bassa frequenza della
nostra ondaradio arriva il nostro
telescopio rispetto alla componente a
frequenza più alta dei nostri
rapidissimi lampi di onde radio possiamo
andare a misurare tutto il gas che il
nostro lampo adatta attraversato per
giungere fino a noi tutto compreso
quello che i nostri telescopi
diversamente non riescono a misurare
perché è un gas così rarefatto così
tenue che non riesce a mettere nessun
tipo di informazioni non fa niente
niente se non frenare la componente a
bassa frequenza dei nostri lampi e così
studiando i nostri lampi noi possiamo a
tutti gli effetti pesare tutto il gas
l'universo e quant'è questo gas è
fortunatamente è tutto quello che
mancava all'appello la teoria del big
bang è salva il nostro viaggio
cominciato più di vent'anni fa in
australia da quella grande antenna
parabolica e da quel piccolo ma lei fico
forno a microonde ci ha portato fino ai
confini dell'universo ma l'esplorazione
del cosmo certo non si fini non si
conclude qui
innanzitutto non sappiamo ancora che
cosa sono benedetti f r b e poi e poi
c'è una cosa che non vi ho detto che in
realtà atto questo bellissimo gas che
noi siamo riusciti finalmente a
tracciare nella sua interezza non
compone co compone un mero 5 per cento
dell'universo il 95 per cento è fatto di
materia oscura ed energia oscura
elementi misteriosi di cui sappiamo poco
o niente sappiamo che devono esistere
perché vediamo i loro effetti in come le
galassie si muovono o in come ad esempio
l'universo si espande ma che
completamente ancora sfuggono alla
registrazione dei nostri strumenti
l'esplorazione del cosmo quindi è appena
agli inizi e il viaggio per arrivare
come direbbe il capitano kirk e là dove
nessuno è mai giunto prima continua
grazie
[Musica]
il mio punto